members of Congress start returning to
Washington DC this morning to work on
ending a six-day partial government
shutdown most national parks and federal
buildings are closed and hundreds of
thousands of federal employees are
working without pay in Iraq President
Trump insisted that the shutdown will
not end until funding is secured for his
border wall we have terrorists coming in
chip Reid is at the White House and
joins us now chip good morning well good
morning lawmakers would like to reopen
the government before the new year but
with both sides taking on my way or the
highway approach that will be a very
difficult task the president refuses to
budge on his demand of five billion
dollars for a border wall and continues
to blame Democrats for obstruction
meanwhile Democrats appear to be holding
firm on their offer of just 1.3 billion
dollars for border security also
Democrats take control of the house on
January 3rd and that will put them in a
much more a much stronger bargaining
position since the shutdown began
Saturday about 420,000 government
employees have been working without pay
and another 380,000 have been furloughed
the House and the Senate
technically speaking come back in
session later today but most of the
members are still home on vacation they
only plan to come back to Washington if
there's a vote and that will only happen
a president Trump and the Democrats
reach a deal on reopening the government
and no one knows when that will be
adrianna chips thank you